the rising cost of just about everything
in america from
cars to travel today's new york post
calls it the incredible shrinking dollar
with
prices rising nearly five and a half
percent year to year
the worst inflation in 13 years some of
the biggest spikes are in the travel
sector leaving many of us struggling to
find
better rates for our getaways errol
barnett is following this errol
what is going on here
yeah hey there adriana good morning look
we have a perfect storm here of high
demand and persistent supply chain
issues
there are increasing numbers of people
who want to get away but there are
decreasing methods of transportation
available to get there
and that means higher costs for all of
us on the move and when you drill
down into these digits though you'll
find some reason for optimism later
and perhaps some tough choices now
i think it's highway robbery it's prices
are ridiculous right now
from california gas stations to florida
hotels the cost of moving around the
country
is up way up including jumps in prices
for airfare and car rentals
we just can't can't afford it tally
halti lives in ohio with her boyfriend
mikey o'malley
her family is in washington state his
are in ireland so the recent increase in
airline prices
means difficult decisions we really want
to go everywhere
do all the things but because of the
prices being so high right now we just
can't
we can't afford the extra trips new
inflation numbers show that when
compared to 2020
gas prices and the cost of used cars and
trucks are each up
more than 45 percent a record jump for
hand vehicles air travel is up more than
24 percent
and the cost of a hotel room up almost
17 percent
this is a phenomenon that is is across
the entire economy
adam sacks is president of tourism
economics and says while this may seem
worrisome looking back further prices
are lower than before the pandemic
we've been spoiled and now we're coming
back to
what might be better considered to be
normal pricing
sachs says expect prices to keep getting
steeper for two reasons
partly because we're not fully back to
where we were
pre-pandemic both on airfares and in
hotel prices
but also because wages are rising in the
industry
because it's been difficult to bring
employees back frustrated travelers may
have to get used to our new
normal and for halti who turns 21 today
that means saving up for a ticket for
when she moves to ireland with her bow
later this year we're still doing what
we need to to get those tickets it's
just
a bit more of a strain than it used to
be on us financially
now united airlines ceo scott kirby on
tuesday said the pandemic is weighing
down business travel
it's at only 60 percent of where it was
in 2019
and adriana the the threat of the delta
vari
variant and virus has its own threat now
to a full
recovery that's right errol thank you so
much you know one thing to keep in mind
though even though this is the worst
inflation rate in 13 years because
prices were so abnormally low
last year it's making this inflation
rate seem so much worse because a lot of
these numbers are comparing
this year yeah to last year it's
unnatural in a lot of ways and by the
way happy
21st birthday to tally halti very cool